what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we're here today to watch
the most popular thing we cover right
here on this very Channel Brooklyn nine
nine episode 14 of season four what's up
mofos alrighty leave a like do it please
for the love of God go to that like
button also full length Reaction watch
along as we sync with your own copy of
Brooklyn Nine-Nine are available for our
super sexy Rejects at our patreon page
we cover so many things exclusively over
there with reaction highlights and watch
alongs included lastly John how are you
I am so good how are you good good
then we're both good
as you know the NYPD intends to shutter
one Precinct in Brooklyn I'll be
evaluating the 99 and sending my
findings to the Deputy Commissioner are
you sure you're the best person for that
job
you know sexual pass
[Laughter]
I wanted the fact that you and I have a
history together affect the decision I
have to make in any way whatsoever well
that's certainly good to hear I mean
sure it took me years of intense therapy
to get over oh my God me a fear of
intimacy that has affected every sub
relationship oh my God no reason I can't
remain unbiased the way you just said
that makes it seem like you actually are
biased I have no idea what you mean
the plan is clear Sarge you divorce
Sharon abandon your children get back
together with that monster the precinct
is saved I'm not leaving my family
give it some thoughts
that's simple okay get divorced get back
with that
what is going on here stupid printer
won't print out my stupid resume which
means I can't send it to any decent
stupid Precinct when this stupid place
shuts down that's not gonna happen why
are you being such a gloomy guess I'm a
realistic Randy didn't go with Rosa huh
it's right there life sucks nothing good
ever happens Scully found a garbage cake
and I found us a dream case involving
One MS Cassie Sinclair from Serve and
Protect yeah that is my favorite cop
show yeah apparently her laptop was
stolen and it had sensitive materials on
it
find out what a horrible thing Terry did
to this woman so he can apologize and
make it right did you cheat on her no I
would never do that did you date one of
her friends right after you broke up I
could optize with all our mutual friends
even Tommy Tommy turned Terry on to
tennis
herb alliteration
time for a little girl talk you really
think you can handle girl talk relax I
got this hey Veronica it's time for some
girl talk
let me see that bra
foreign
[Laughter]
and being invited to a party at George
Clooney's Villa where he pranks me and
then we prank Matt Damon together and
then Damon's like Peralta you got the
goods you're gonna be the star of my
next movie I do want to be a movie star
I like the way you wear your badge can I
steal that absolutely oh hey here's
another little nugget for you if you'd
like thanks for coming down to the
precinct
wouldn't the person already know that if
they were at the precinct
yep someone broken in my trailer Jimmy
the lock found out this morning from the
second A.D oh A.D announcing Department
assistant director oh that's even better
hey hi Cassie who is this this guy from
the NYPD they're here about my laptop oh
I didn't think you were going to involve
the cops in this but well that's okay
here they are suspect Numero Uno I know
what she's going through I've been
broken up with six times really only six
yep does it count if they end the
relationship but still want to be
friends yes yes oh in 210.
ouch
is there anyone above her that you can
appeal to she reports the Deputy
Commissioner Grayson I've already tried
to set up a meeting with him he's on
vacation with his family in the Poconos
okay
find out where he's staying and just
happen to run into him and accidentally
strike a political convo about the nine
nine well that's going to rather
underhanded desperate times call for
Desperate Housewives all right measures
I said measures sure you're a bad
influence I mean I've never been a bad
influence on anyone should I bring my
leather jacket it's ankle length and
fitted yeah I'm gonna bring it it's too
nice
you kids are gonna be all right nine
times out of ten in a case like this
it's a stalker whoever Jimmy the lock
didn't know what they were doing I
concur this no that was it real hot jump
what Deborah he plays to take the cold
tracker awesome the next thing you're
gonna say is so what's it gonna be rock
paper scissors or gun
it's been in here since the incident
what's he doing he just thinks he's a
detective because he's been playing one
for 15 years I can hear you uh look at
the time well they need you on the side
Cassie I'll walk you over you are so
suspicious has anyone noticed this crumb
you might want to bag that it's in boys
of the lab
but in real life when we handle evidence
we gotta wear gloves never wear gloves
on the show fans will love to see my
fingers almost as much as they love
seeing my feed Google it no oh man you
got side hustle would you ever consider
being a Consulting producers for the
show Absolutely what does that mean well
we'd pay you to come in in your off
hours talk to the writers tell them your
stories let the show a little
authenticity he's going to run it by the
studio Rosa I told you good cops you do
your job things will work out so dumb
world I think that job offers bogus he's
trying to buy us off I don't know about
you but I can't be bought off and it's
gonna take a hell of a lot more than
some job offer to make me compromise the
Integrity of the badge Hey Jake catering
sent over some chicken fingers yeah
that's what badge we're hanging out with
cool people don't ruin this with all
your rosiness think about it that
producer guy didn't want to see her at
all and then after watching us work for
like two seconds he offers us a job it
doesn't make sense that's just how
Showbiz Works your room
he doesn't want us to solve the crime so
he is buying us off it's shady I love
the shade it keeps the Sun away on hot
days
he and Cassie have been fighting about
her contract it's been all over the news
the trades they call them the trades
here we read them in our trailers after
we wrap and before we go home fun fact
Stars use the word home too they're just
like us
[Laughter]
I planned a perfect breakup I even got
her a classy breakup present plus a gift
receipt in case you wanted to exchange
it you deserve a man that can make you
happy and it is the greatest displeasure
of my life that I could not be that man
thank you Terrence
[Laughter]
I call the secretary and pretended to be
his mother or should I say the
lesson she's like it's a little trick I
picked up from the original Bad Boy Oh
Mr Bugs Bunny yeah buddy captain of the
nine nine what are you doing here I'm on
vacation while we're on the subject of
um
things are you by any chance in charge
of the Brooklyn Precinct contraction if
you have an issue bring it up with your
Predator well our order is actually
listen oh no if you think you're helping
your precincts cause you're not
hey sexy are you ready to go oh you are
oh I'm not saying blackmail on blackmail
him we just insinuate that we know
what's going on and let him fill in the
blanks oh so it's like
he blackmails himself
how's your wife commissioner Grayson
how's your wife no that just sounds like
you really want to know
[Laughter]
use your eyebrows like this how's your
pump wife pump pump how about pump pump
how's your pump you forgot to say wife
oh goodness
Gary lormax do you know where he was on
the night of the rubber last night he
did ask me to tell him when Cassie left
her trailer hmm interesting is that
normally an executive producer's job
well I'm trying to be more Hands-On
Network pressure overages overages sure
I get those on my cell phone
and I introduce you to the writers it
just took a couple of minutes tops lead
the way hombre hey if you name a
character after me that could be a
sketch phrase I love that
what's the twist we have a case to work
that's why we got to meet the writers
wake up you are being manipulated by our
Prime Suspect all right he's subprime at
best
so Prime Mortgage crisis reference
I have to think the worst of everyone
because that's how you see life it's sad
you're sad and you're being a bad cop oh
but I'm in such a good mood about all of
this that there's literally nothing you
can say that'll Bring Me Down lead the
way ombre is a terrible catchphrase nice
try to hurt my feelings
[Laughter]
looks like they left housekeeping one
hell of a tip
fingertip
and that's how I would lift up a bloody
finger with my pen that is great
what are you doing talking to Cassie and
the writers who BT dubs all have Alibis
also Gary said that the studio approved
us as producers I'm having my agent look
over the paperwork
we've been going for a while you're
feeling hungry starving thanks
oh
yogurt yogurt I even gave Veronica
plenty of time after her mom's death
wait what does that mean I was gonna
break up with her but then her mom
passed so like a gentleman I waited that
way she wouldn't have to deal with too
much pain all at once how long no year
year and a half years what I was being
considerate believe me she had her fun
for those 18 months Terry puts out why
the gift you bought her did you buy it
when you first wanted to break up with
her or when you finally did it the first
time but why would that matter
the gift we see they all break
eventually damn
commissioner
Grayson Captain Holt I told you I'm not
going to get involved I know
I just wanted to say
[Music]
I love the 99 and the main reason why is
you not Jake yes clearly it's mostly
Jake but it's also you I'd rather we
split up than stay together and
compromise Who We Are
[ __ ]
we'll feel better knowing we didn't
resort to Blackmail I agree from now on
the only black male I want anything to
do with is you you and Terry security
cam caught you breaking into Cassie's
trailer and walking off at this backpack
you know what you Hollywood types make
me sick detective for the record your
show sticks I've watched over 200
episodes of it and I've never liked one
no
it's a bunch of pills Cassie has a
painkiller problem the show tries to
protect her from herself that's why I
was surprised she called the cops but
thanks for busting in here and telling
me how much you hate my show and scene
making a mistake that's the kind of
thing we can go over more when I come in
on Monday for my first day of work no
you can forget about the job but you're
still gonna name a character after me oh
Rosa everything sucks we're never gonna
solve the case I'll never work in Show
Business and I'll never drink another
smoothie now you're getting it we won't
be friends anymore you don't actually
think that we won't be friends anymore
if the precinct gets shut down
we will never not be friends
thanks man oh get your hand off me yep
forgot the rosary rule everything's not
awful
I just solved the case
season 8 episode 16 in which detective
Cole tracker catches the Brooklyn bra
butcher while wearing gloves I thought
Mark said his character never wears
gloves on the show now that you mention
it that does ring a bell interesting I
knew it you wanted to see you holding
the bag because your prints were already
on it Cassie's only been on the show two
years but there's already taka for
getting a spin-off you were going to
post her personal photos and humiliator
ridiculous I've never been more insulted
in my life
Cassie's laptop in the trunk of your car
I stand corrected yeah you got me I did
it
good job
but you don't have to forgive me but
could you please at least give the
precinct a shot except I've already
turned in my report positive no it was
real bad
oh Jesus no your sister and I gonna Trot
you all around the apartment what's
what's wrong I'm Jake Peralta of course
the grossest pervert of all time
rest you unbelievable creep you'll never
take me alive
hahaha
[Music]
yep yep yep
rotten hell Jake Peralta
[Music]
do you use my name
yes
success oh
how
rewarding that that was a delight that
was so good
so funny so funny
well John please
it was a delightful episode I should
have called out Nathan Fillion I knew it
would be him the Gary guy was just too
suspicious he's too perfect
and uh and yeah Nathan Fillion I'm like
too big of a guest actor not to be
involved somehow but I liked it I I
liked I always am fascinated when the
show like this has an opportunity to go
do like an episode where you're on a set
because I'm like was that just
somebody's fun idea or was this like
helping out the budget for this part of
the Season just right I have to go
anywhere we could just go on the line
shoot in an empty Sound Stage
um but yeah I thought the fun and game I
mean the the the Amy uh the the Rosa and
Peralta plot was you know like the
Lion's Share of the episode and I think
that part shown the brightest I enjoyed
the rest of it
um mostly with them just trying to
interrogate Terry
um but like yeah the the most hilarious
bits I thought were in the uh the
investigation of the laptop and when
boil and uh Holtz are trying to figure
out what to do with their eyebrows
together uh you know like the the I'm
curious about how the rest of this
Precinct getting shut down plot line is
gonna go because right now you know
looks like the precinct is in danger of
getting shut down but we know that's not
gonna happen
and uh
I'm curious like that part of the
episode felt maybe a little more engaged
at the in the previous one than it did
here but I still enjoyed everything that
we cut to I still had a blast watching
this and Gina is making progress she's
out of the Halo good for her
almost a little sad but she's not still
hit it because I've made for a lot of
very uh funny stuff and uh yeah what do
you think sir
I thought it was funny
that is the main goal of any Brooklyn
Nine-Nine episode is to nail down the
funny and they nail down the funny
the funny got me laughing truly laughing
quite a bit here
um I like Boyle and Holt being paired
off together
watching them learn the moral lesson of
not blackmailing
which I would have done why not
the guy's a cheater screw it yeah that's
the worst thing you could do
he's cheating on his wife
with a young hot Asian woman yeah white
people love Asian people do I blame him
absolutely not
but I could use it against him sure
yeah that's a good moral line to draw
that you're a good guy
never stoop to such lows
so yes there's that
yeah the stuff on set that must be cool
for a cop
let's look down upon
I look down upon like some type of
sellout are you like a looked at as a
sellout cop
you go to network TV and you become a
consultant
I've always wondered that like you're
not a real cop you're just in it for the
money the glory if you walk into the
precinct and everyone just calls you
Hollywood from now on
well you see what I've come to realize
growing up
from when I was a child oh that's where
the growing up started
okay yeah yeah
I like many had this impression
that people who became cops all them
dreamed of it they wanted to be heroes
and serve people in their country and
they really believed in Justice and then
as I got older and by older I mean like
two years ago I realized there's a lot
of people who just did it because they
they just needed a job sure they just
became cops because I got nothing else
to do yeah and it seems like a fine pay
that I'm like oh no wonder there's a lot
of corruption you get the benefits and
all that yeah yeah you get the best it's
like most people are not Serpico most
importantly not Jake Peralta or or most
of the people in in Brooklyn nine it's
just not most cops
so with that in mind I'm like yeah if I
became a cop I totally use it to work my
way up to becoming a consultant on a TV
show why not why not I have no real
passion to become a police officer but
if I had uh
down that path because I just had to I
do a good job but I'd also be like all
right it's time to become a consultant
but they're detectives yeah they're not
like
yeah
yeah so that would be that so yeah is
that does that look down upon a Wonder
but I like the I liked how this played
on the fantasy of Jake Peralta wanting
to be a movie cop in his own way a TV
show hero cop and that was funny
it was really funny and they had me
going because it seemed like it was
really I thought it was going to be
something where Jake learns his lesson
like I thought it was going to end
shortly after they confront the producer
and I was like oh
that's a turn of events
playing on the real life Stephanie
Beatrice sure yeah I was addicted to
pills exactly bringing look it up guys
it really happened Google she dealt with
it was through this episode it was very
real it all 100 happened I'm not making
stuff up I don't do that here no that's
very real
and uh there's another plot line oh yeah
and I also like Terry you know realizing
because these Terrys look at this such
like a good guy the nice guy the family
man
then to see that ah even he makes
mistakes sometimes that niceness can get
in the way yeah all right we should
relate to that yeah sometimes you try to
be so nice that you actually kind of
screw things up worse mm-hmm
well that was a pretty big oversight on
his part
damn dude shouldn't have given the gift
for that gift receipt that was a great
detail of like as as much as as that
plot wasn't the funniest plot of the
episode I did appreciate that plot for
the resolve that it brought it was very
satisfying to get to the end of that and
be like ah damn it man that's a very
human error yeah I thought we were gonna
have some like a little bit more fun
back and forth with that Veronica girl
and yeah Terry but we didn't do that and
just kind of kept apart the whole time
that's what I mean is like you know
having having uh Teddy was like such an
Engaged thing and I get that you can't
maybe do like the same kind of episode
again but but it would have been
different for Terror Bear yeah sure and
it felt like even though that was part
of the stakes of the episode it felt
sort of like distant from the main
action going down
my God okay so this can has 300
milligrams and this one has a 140. wow
that's different from each other there's
a significant milligram dosage I'm gonna
really choose the flavor right yeah oh
my God
they both they both
you know tout Extreme Performance and
focus
why are they so different
I don't know why does Mega Man Mega Man
why does Megan maybe because he's Mega
it's got to be double
well if I drink them both it'll be it'll
be yeah it'll be 440 milligrams of
caffeine which would be awesome Mega Man
ones are good though
I know they're delicious wow that's a
lot of caffeine
who needs sleep
uh anyway that was a good episode thank
you guys for being here and enjoying
Brooklyn nine nine with us it's always a
treat it's good comfort food
my police family
this show is the single reason I love
cops as much as I do
so a patron of the day shout out
David Gandy gonna be investigating you
David I've heard some terrible things
about you
I've heard that maybe after all this
time you're not the nice generous guy
you are what I have come to discover
that everything you have gifted us with
you have stolen from orphanages ah that
frame photo of John Wayne you took from
an eight-year-old Puerto Rican boy in
New York City now what's he gonna pray
to how can you do such a thing yeah he
needed that and the nun was really upset
in that that boy he got an ass whooping
by you that nun
yeah both yeah
so yeah man you done messed up the
Gravity Falls
right off a kid's head you took that off
of a child's head and then you beat that
child yeah now was the video funny it
was a little funny
but was it wrong
depends who you talk to I say it's wrong
I say I stand by the side that you
shouldn't have beat him despite how
hilarious that video ended up being you
shouldn't have done it I say there's
nothing not enough evidence that's true
it could have been any white but anyway
man it'll all look alike they all look
alike especially David typical looking
white man white guy with glasses like
that's the best disguise out there also
you uh did a couple of videos were you
saying to us and you sent us a video on
a phone
found out the fake yeah and the song was
stolen too that's right yeah you didn't
write the Happy Birthday song he did not
and he took a deep fake
of
Prince yeah
I really thought Prince just cared
enough to have recorded those videos for
us in advance but it turns out it was
all
the prince
Still Still David
you can't just saying that I can and
I'll just find your way now the Now it's
now we're going down a path princess
David this whole time Prince was like
David I'll record the music and then you
just deep fake your face on oh whatever
David thanks for being here sorry guys I
appreciate it you can arrest me now it's
okay bye David sorry sorry I got messed
up
[Music]
oh